[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et tous et merci de
nous rejoindre sur TVfil 78 pour un
nouveau numéro du 78 société la question
du soir quelle réponse apporter à la
radicalisation liée à l'islam vous
pouvez poser toutes vos questions et
participer à l'émission via les réseaux
sociaux sur notre Twitter ht78 sociciété
la radicalisation gagne du terrain dans
le pays le département des ivelines est
particulièrement touché selon les
chiffres donnés début février par le
préfet des ivelines Serge Morvent en
2015 300 personnes ont été signalées et
font l'objet d'une fiche s la fameuse
fiche S pour handiguer ce phénomène
alarmant de nombreux dispositifs ont été
mis en place par l'État numéros vert
sites internet cellules de suivi et
autres sont-ils efficaces quelles sont
les solutions proposées par les acteurs
de terrain comment se fait la prévention
en milieu carcéral quel rôle enfin
jouent les mosquées et les associations
musulmanes pour prévenir la
radicalisation pour en débattre avec
nous nos invités Habiba bil bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes coordinatrice du
projet déradicalisation pour
l'association sansmur merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation Marie lur Segal
et Samir messiba bonsoir à tous les deux
vous êtes à l'origine du collectif
parole à cœur ouvert un collectif é
après les attentats de janvier 2015 pour
notamment promouvoir le vivre ensemble à
trrape et àentour merci également
d'avoir répondu à notre appel et enfin
Monsieur Abdelaziz El jawari vous êtes
secrétaire général du Simi le SIMI c'est
le conseil des institutions musulmanes
des évelines bonsoir bonsoir merci de
invitation merci merci d'être venu alors
on va faire un premier tour de table sur
ce terme ce phénomène qu'on entend
beaucoup et l'augmentation des cas de
radicalisation quel constat vous pouvez
faire vous sur le terrain comment vous
voyez ça concrètement comment ça se
concrétise cette montée de la
radicalisation sur le terrain
ABAB peut-être pour commencer ou sur le
terrain on remarque une très grande
confusion au niveau du terme déjà au
niveau de la radicalisation qu'est-ce
qu'on y met hein qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière en fait mange un peu tout
voulez dire oui tout à fait euh les
causes le public concerné en tout cas
nous par rapport à l'association pour
laquelle je travaille euh on se rend
compte que par exemple en en milieu
carcéral il y a les détenus sont sont
rassemblés et en fait entre euh par
rapport aux faits euh le les les faits
qu'ils ont commis tout à fait par
rapport aux faits qui ont été commis
certains ont été en syyrie d'autres part
certains ont commis des atrocités
d'autres d'autres part donc il y a quand
même une échelle euh où euh en fait on
se pose aussi la question est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose de les rassembler
entre eux donc voilà il y a aussi la
stigmatisation et l'amalgame entre
détenus hein c'est quelque chose que
vous entendez également tout à fait de
grandes interrogations et d'angoisse au
sujet de l'état d'urgence également et
puis effectivement ce que vous disiez là
tout à l'heure
de de l'appréhension au sujet de la
déchéance de la
nationté des fiches s apparemment on en
recenserait 9000 9000 en France 9000 en
France effectivement selon les derniers
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur on
va continuer ce premier tour de table
peut-être Abdelaziz aljbar d'abord
ensuite on donnera la parole au
collectif oui bonsoir sur la question de
la radicalisation ma première remarque
c'est de dire que on a plusieurs couches
de la société qui se radicalise euh ces
dernières années donc on le voit
d'ailleurs dans la montée de tous les
extrêmes il y a les extrêmes religieux
mais il y a aussi les extrêmes
politiques euh donc je pense qu'on est
en en plein dans l'actualité de ce point
de on est dans une époque de l'extrême
je dirais pas ça mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que il y a il y a une
donne internationale et puis il y a il y
a y a à la fois géopolitique mais aussi
le contexte économique qu' soit mondial
et et et même national qui ne facilite
pas les choses donc à partir de là vous
avez un certain nombre d'ingrédient euh
qui en effet euh simplifie en tout cas
facilite le travail euh de de
prédicateur de de de de toutes ces
théories de radicalisation qu'elle soit
une radicalisation politique religieuse
ou autre donc voilà donc ça c'est la la
le premier élément le deuxième élément
sur la la la la question liée au
radicalisme que on empute à à la
question de de de l'Islam ou des musulm
euh donc c'est un fait aujourd'hui il y
a des chiffres il y a un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont impliquées dans
des atrocités bon on a eu la une année
dramatique 2015 euh donc voilà est-ce
que pour autant c'est une c'est
suffisant pour faire des généralités je
ne pense pas du tout je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion de
revenir dessus au cours du débat Marie
lorsogan moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord parce que je pense que vous
dites que ce qui est ce qui ce qui est
extrême c'est aussi bien ce qui est
politique que l'extrémisme se trouve
aussi bien dans des attitudes politiques
moi j'ai envie de reprendre ce que dit
Olivier rois concernant l'islamisation
de la radicalité et je crois que c'est
quand même sur ce phénomène là qu'on est
aujourd'hui rassemblé et que il faut
appeler un chat un chat ça veut pas dire
qu'après il y a des différences comme
vous avez dit entre les salafistes tous
les salafistes sont pas des terroristes
et bon il y a beaucoup de de gens qui
interviennent là-dessus mais je trouve
qu'ici on est quand même venu pour
parler de cette radical cette
islamisation de la radicalité et qui je
crois est un phénomène qui nous
interroge aujourd'hui Sam REM pour
terminer ce premier tour de table oui je
dirais aussi que il peut y avoir la
radicalisation de l'islamité dans dans
dans dans l'autre sens mais ce qui nous
interpelle nous par rapport à toutes ces
questions euh c'est au niveau de la
catégorie de de jeunes qu'on qu'on qu'on
travaille on réfléchit au sein du
collectif parole à cœur ouvert voilà
pour présenter un peu notre notre
collectif alors justement on est là pour
parler de de de cette thématique et puis
des dispositifs mis en place par l'État
du coup un numéro vert un site internet
et puis des cellules de suivi de
déradicalisation pour les appeler ainsi
dans les préfectures ou autour alors on
voit le le numéro qui s'affiche donc le
0800005
686 alors comment vous jugez-vous les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place par
l'État est-ce que ce sont des
dispositifs suffisamment connus du
public est-ce que ce sont des
dispositifs qui sont efficaces Marie
lgal je veux bien intervenir souvent
moqué hein quand on parle par exemple du
site stop jihadisme souvent tourné en
dérision même dans les médias oui euh
sans parler des analyses qui existe au
niveau de livres sérieux comme parole
armée qui est un un essai qui me paraît
très intéressant qui justement montre
combien les la façon dont l'état tente
de réagir à ce phénomène semble pas
toujours adéquate pour je veux pas
m'étendre là-dessus je dirais aussi que
au niveau de trappe entre autres
puisquon peut parler que de ce qu'on
connaît un tout petit peu il y a des
mamans que l'on connaît qui soit
ont été dénoncé entre guillemets le
vivent comme ça parce que leur fils
était parti et que elles étaient sur
écoute ouelles ont téléphoné à une
copine
ou et finalement donc elles ont été
découvertes entre guillemets avec elle
aussi le même le même hélas la même le
même chagrin mais il y en existe aussi
qui ne veulent pas se dénoncer entre
guillemets et elles vivent ça comme se
dénoncer non pas appeler au secours mais
se dénoncer parce que les perquisitions
se font de façon
euh très très violente euh voilà donc il
y a quand même il
semblerait un décalage entre ce que
l'État essaie de mettre en place et la
façon dont les gens le ressent et
l'éprouve ababelli oui il faudrait
davantage coupler en fait l'offre de
sensibilisation vers les jeunes ce qui
ce qui est déjà mis en place c'est bien
mais en même temps est-ce que est-ce que
les personnes voilà ce que vous disiez
là madame Segal est-ce que les personne
l'entourage est-ce est-ce que
l'entourage est à même de d'aller faire
cette démarche toute la complexité elle
est là aussi donc c'est à un moment
donné comment on on sensibilise les gens
pour faire entendre que c'est c'est plus
aussi de l'ORD de aussi le statut de
victime finalement pour pour leur pour
pour la la personne qui
sera voilà quand on
appellera là on assiste à à comment
dire à l'apparition d'un certain nombre
de dispositifs en effet que ça soit au
niveau du service de l'État au niveau du
ministère de la Justice au niveau du
parquet euh et ainsi de suite donc euh
là je pense que globalement on est au
mode réaction et c'est tout à fait
normal quand on voit là encore
l'atrocité des événements de 2015 donc
c'est tout à fait euh compréhensible
mais je pense qu'il faut un peu de temps
et un peu de recul euh pour euh comment
dire poser des des des vrais diagnostics
et euh une méthodologie de travail parce
que il y a plein d'associations avec des
professionnels qui s'installent et qui
qui veulent travailler sur le sujet et
et et pourquoi pas euh donc voilà
nous-même on a été sollicité par un
certain nombre ou par les institutions
publiques dans ce cadrel dans un cadre
de réflexion sur ces questions de
radicalisation et comment travailler
avec un public même dit radicaliser et
ainsi de suite donc voilà je pense que
je suis pas sûr qu'on en est à un stade
aujourd'hui pour porter un comment dire
un jugement ou faire un bilan de de ces
dispositifs qui qui qui commenc c'est
c'est trop tôt pour c'est quand même
depuis 2014 c'est avant les attentats
dit mais les dispositifs mais les les
les dispositifs ils sont quand même euh
euh tous euh très très récents voilà et
et c'est vrai par rapport à ce qui a été
dit euh c'est qu' il y a une aujourd'hui
voilà il y a les dispositifs qui se
mettent en place mais vous avez aussi
des perquisitions administratives il y a
aussi un état d'urgence donc le grand
public est un peu perdu entre entre tout
ça donc voilà et après il y a les
conditions dans lesquelles ça se passe
je suis pas sûr que dans en tout cas
dans les Yvelines globalement en tout
cas j'ai pas l'impression que que qu'il
y ait eu tant de d'excès que ça mais par
contre bon j'étais il y a 15 jours à
l'audience solennelle du tribunal
administratif et de la cour d'appel
administrative et un des sujets qui a
été abordé justement c'est la saisine du
tribunal administratif dans dans les cas
de perquisition ou de d'assignation à
résidence voilà donc aujourd'hui comprè
l'institution judiciire à les mobiliser
sur sur cette partie là parce que vous
avez des familles ou des personnes qui
trouvent qu'ils ont été injustement
traités et que il y a eu des amalgames
et donc là il y a il y a il y a des
voies de recours
légales con ça je voulais préciser par
rapport à ce dispositif mais tous des
dispositifs qui ne reposent pas euh sur
en bas sur un relais dans au sein de la
société civil qui ne qui n'a pas de
pédagogie une façon de faire je pense il
vou l'éche il peut être voué à à l'échec
mais il demande beaucoup de temps pour
que qu'il porte ses fruits je voudrais
préciser il faut qu'il soit étayé il
faut qu'il y ait aussi des des des
acteurs de la société même dans le
réseau amical ou associatif qui peut qui
peut porter ça c'est c'est eux qui
peuvent approcher les parents qui sont
en désari par rapport à des questions de
leurs gamins qui amè des questions
d'ordre phénomène drive secteur oui donc
pour vous il faut pas uniquement compter
sur des apports exérieurs de l'État faut
également comme vous l' fait avec le
collectif paroleur cœur ouvert voilà ou
en fait par rapport Mo moi ça me renvoie
au fait là ce que vous venez de de dire
Samir c'est que le numéro vert par
exemple moi je donne l'exemple du numéro
vert c'est c'est à la fois
euh ça peut être intéressant et je pense
que du coup c'est c'est intéressant et
en même temps on envoie pas les fruits
effectivement maintenant et en même
temps ça peut porter on revient à ce que
je disais tout à l'heure à à un amalgame
c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce pourquoi on appelle est-ce que
c'est parce que voilà qu'est-ce qu'on
met dans radicalisation est-ce que le
fait de porter un dilbeb est-ce que le
fait de de d'avoir une barbe voilà en
fait c'est est-ce que les signes
extérieurs sont signes de radicalité
donc voilà ou est-ce qu'on est pas en
train est-ce qu'on est pas en train de
se tromper de de sujet est-ce que le la
la radicalisation est-ce que c'est pas
tout autre chose hein ce serait parce
que quand on voit l'histoire des
radicalisation des des différentes
radicalités qui ont traversé le 20e
siècle c'est c'est porté vers la
violence et on peut
pas voilà
c'est le risque qui qui pourrait se
poser c'est qu'il ait des appels
anonymes qu'on des des dénonciation de
voisinage et cetera c'est l'inquiétude
moi j'ai entendu des ce type de de
situation et donc ça peut être très très
inquiétant ensite numéro vert
perquisition et cetera et cetera avec
c'est pour ça justeouter pour compléter
c'est pour ça quand je parler de de
pédagogie il s'agit de d'accompagnement
des des parents et des familles et non
pas sous forme que ce dispositif soit
vécu comme une forme de de délation ou
de donc voilà c'est beaucoup plus pour
accompagner rassurer les les les
familles euh pour qu'ils aient la bonne
information qu' qui ce soit pas comme ça
un appel comme vous dites c'est quoi ce
numéro il y a beaucoup de numéros verts
de toutes les façons bon donc et du coup
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
contournent un petit peu Cees dispositif
et qui vont par exemple vous avez été
contacter vous directement par des
personnes via le collectif par le cœur
ouvert on a comme ça une mère qui est
aux aboir et qui nous a joint parce
qu'elle voulait venir témoigner on
espère qu'on en aura d'autres euh au
sein du collectif pour justement se
sentir moins seul pour informer enfin
c'est sa forme de résilience et euh pour
précisit c'est une maman dont la fille
euh a failli partir don la fille a
failli partir et euh donc et et je crois
que elle est toujours aussi démunie même
si cette jeune n'est pas partie et on
espère que ça fera venir d'autres maères
qui aujourd'hui n'osent pas encore venir
dans le collectif on les connaît elles
peuvent nous parler de façon euh
individuelle mais elles n'osent pas
encore venir témoigner au sein du
collectif pour vous montrer où on en est
dans dans la difficulté d'établir un
climat de confiance vraiment établir un
climat de confiance alors justement je
vous je vous coupe un petit instant
messieurs dames on est allé demander
l'avis des sainqutinois sur sur la
question on leur a demandé que
faudrait-il faire selon eux pour lutter
contre la radicalisation on revient
juste après en plateau pour vos réaction
je pense qu'il faudrait éduquer dans les
dans les églises dans les mosquées dans
les synagogues les gens avec les vrais
textes les textes je dirais d'origine
sans y mettre
son point de vue personnel pour servir
ses propres intérêts je pense que avec
l'école on a un certain point de vue
soit on y adhère soit on prend un point
de vue autre que celui de ses parents
puisque souvent c'est l'éducation des
parents qui se transm aux enfants ça
passe avant tout par l'éducation je
pense ce serait enfin c'est surtout des
jeunes qui sont touchés et issus de un
peu n'importe quelle famille n'importe
quel milieu donc ce qui serait bien
justement ce serait de peut-être de
faire plus prendre conscience de des
dangers aux jeunes peut-être des cours
sur la religion des choses comme ça ça
pourrait peut-être aider un peu les
jeunes à mieux comprendre mieux
concevoir ce que c'est l'islam et et
voilà je pense que ce sera déjà un bon
début on dit que les armes tu les tuent
les terroristes on dit que l'éducation
tue le terrorisme en fait faudrait
donner plus d'opportunités aux jeunes et
leur donner un peu plus de comment je
peux dire ça faudrait faut leur faut les
encadrer pour leur avenir parce que
quand tu laisses un jeune tu vois faire
toute la journée excusez-moi du terme
mais quand on s'emmerde toute la journée
tu crois que la première chose qui va
venir à l'esprit c'est quoi c'est de
faire des conneries mais si les jeunes
ils sont occupés il tu vois ils ont un
travail ils ont un avenir ou en tout cas
ils sentent qu'ils ont un avenir sans
leur faire sentir qu'ils sont capables
de faire des choses qu'ils sont capables
de faire des grandes choses parce qu'on
est tous capablebl de faire des choses
on a tous un cerveau tu vois je pense
que si vraiment on s'occupe de la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui et ben on fera un
monde meilleur demain inchallah alors
éducation école parents cours religion
travail avenir c'est les mots clés qui
ressortent de ce de ce ce micro trottoir
en fait si je justement c'est c'est on
en parlait tout à l'heure on parlait
plutôt des conséquences et en effet le
vrai travail il est travaillé sur les
causes de cette radicalisation je pense
que dans votre reportage ça a été repris
à juste titre les les vraies questions
sont plutôt d'ordre de au niveau de
l'éducation sur la question sociale sur
la question de l'accès à l'emploi les
discriminations et ainsi de suite ça
veut pas dire là encore que au nom de
ces difficulté on peut excuser ou
justifier un passage à l'acte on peut
c'est inexcusable ça peut pas aucun sous
aucun prétexte mais ceci dit il y a il
faut quand même travailler sur ce
terreau là l'accès à la culture c'est
très important donc voilà vraiment la
dimension de de de de la culture et de
de l'accès à un certain nombre de de de
comment dire de moyens et et d'outils
assez jeunes et notamment au niveau de
l'adolescence tout tout cet encadrement
parce que à un certain âge les jeunes
veulent affirmer leur personnalité
vis-à-vis de la cellule familial
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur vis-à-vis de
l'autorité aussi et donc à ce moment-là
en effet si vous n'avez pas
l'encadrement nécessaire et ben les
jeunes en cour circuitant les réseaux
sur la question religieuse bah c'est pas
à la mosquée qu'on va y aller on va y
aller sur les réseaux sociaux sur la
question c'est pas aux parents qu'on va
poser la question on va y aller avec ses
copains dans la rue et ainsi de suite
donc la la question de l'encadrement est
extrêmement primordiale alors un des
éléments qui est souvent repris dans les
médias c'est le lien entre la prison et
la radicalisation alors que ça est-ce
que ça un fait établi ça pour vous qui
intervenez notamment dans les dans dans
les prisons oui en fait cette question
soulève en fait ça amène une autre
question est-ce que les jeunes se
radicalisent se radicalisent-il
davantage en prison alors la prison
c'est quand même un lieu de souffrance
c'est un lieu aussi de de désespoir donc
voilà c'est un peu le c'est un peu le le
dernier palier pour le pour la personne
voilà elle est arrivé peu un peu comme
sielle est arrivé au bout du cheminement
et et à un moment donné
c'est le besoin un peu de le détenu a
besoin de valorisation donc un d'être
reconnu de de de faire partie d'un d'un
groupe de père père Pirs bien sûr bien
entendu et donc le fait de de voilà ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'en prison il y a
un regain de
religiosité ce regain de religiosité il
est pas il est pas en adéquation avec
avec ce qui est proposé en prison à la
fois il y a peu de salalles de culte he
peu de lieux de culte adaptés dans les
prisons française très pe Dom musulman
également également tout à fait et euh
donc il y a trop peu aussi également
d'espac de parole notamment les espaces
de paroes qui sont liés à des sujets en
lien avec la société civile he avec des
gens de l'extérieur qui pourrai
intervenir et nous justement voilà
après l'assoation vous allez essayer de
mettre en place avec tout à fait oui oui
oui des solution qui existe Sam mess oui
je voulais rebondir sur la question de
de milieu carcéral c'est vrai que nous à
l'extérieur on a pour vous je précise je
n'ai pas dire en introduction vous êtes
éducateur spécialisé c'est V votre
métier tout à fait donc nous de
l'extérieur on connaî très peu le le le
le milieu carcéral mais de de ce qu'on
entend de ce qu'on de ce que j'ai lu et
donc ce que j'ai entendu
c'est dans un contexte pareil quelqu'un
qui est en prison il y a il y a quelque
chose qui est un petit peu occulté à
travers tous les intervenants les
questions d'ordre spirituel existentiel
c'est à ce moment-là donc s'il y a pas
un
accompagnement un soutien sur ces
questions elles peuvent être d'ordre
philosophique aussi s'il y a rien qui
est étayé euh donc il y a d'autres
courants qui prennent en charge ça qui
donne des réponses voilà c'est sur cette
question existentielle et il y ça qui
qui est qui est survolé je dirais même
en en milieu carcéral il y a aussi la
question de la réinsertion comment la
réinsertion elle est elle est travaillée
quand on voit qu'un conseiller d'intion
et pration à à 120 dossiers à son actif
hein les détenus sont des dossiers et
que finalement euh les 3/4 des détenus
quand ils sortent il y a pas de projet
donc c'est aussi ça c'est qu'en est-il
de la réinsertion et encore plus quand
on parle aussi de réadaptation à la
société civile et donc généralement
effectivement ça rejoint en fait cette
question ça rejoint aussi la question de
de finalement au niveau de l'aspect de
l'individu c'estàdire sa place dans la
société mais aussi en tant qu'individu
comment on fait à un moment donné pour
que qu'il fasse aussi un travail sur sa
propre existence au-delà de sa place
dans la société civile la société civile
je crois que c'est a aussi une réflexion
à voir sur la fameuse identité un des
problèmes aujourd'hui je pense au niveau
des jeunes et des jeunes qui sont en
prison aussi c'est que clairement déjà
isé de l'immigration si on parle
d'identité oui enfin je dirais oui mais
ça peut être aussi bien des Corses ça
peut être moi
j'élargirais non mais voilà j'élargirai
délibérément en ce moment c'estàd que
quand l'identité l'emporte sur d'autres
ça devient un piège sur les questions
sociales ce que vous avez dit aussi je
crois qu'à ce moment-là la question de
la citoyenneté paraît très artificielle
très secondaire et je crois que c'est un
des problèmes c'est que l'identité doit
être mise à sa juste place et que la
citoyenneté mais pour que la citoyenneté
soit vécue comme quelque chose
d'attirant encore faut-il que les
problèmes de société bon en ce moment on
discute comme vous savez de du Code du
travail c'est vrai que tout ce qui
s'annonce on a l'impression que ça va
être ça va aller de de de pire en pire
donc il y a de quoi s'inquiéter et je
pense que on se réfugie dans les
questions d'identité l'identité devient
un refuge c'est un refuge alors
justement un petit quelques petits
chiffres pour continuer on va continuer
à discuter encore un petit peu
concernant la
radicalisation alors entre 2014 et 2015
donc d'avril 2014 à fin juin 2015
2489 signalements de radicalisation sur
11000 appels reçus donc à ce fameux
numéro de téléphone qu'on a qu'on a cité
tout à l'heure et un chiffre qui va vous
marquer dans les chiffres qui vont
apparaître également à l'écran euh c'est
les 56 % que vous voyez en bas de
l'écran donc les radicalisés sont des
personnes converti à l'islam pour 56 %
des cas voilà il y a d'autres chiffres
que vous pouvez découvrir notamment
concernant les mineur voilà et puis les
différences entre les garçons et les
filles alors justement Abdelaziz al
jawari 56 % de convertis dans les
personnes qui ont été signalé ou fiché
comme radicalisé qu'est-ce que vous en
en tant que Simi donc conseil
institution des les institutions
musulmanes de des evelines vous faites
concrètement dans les mosquées dans les
associations pour peut-être accueillir
ces un nouveaux convertis ou même plus
largement les jeunes les jeunes
musulmans en fait globalement et au
quotidien nos institutions que ce soit
les mosquées les salles de prière bon
comme vous le savez accueil
quotidiennement un public est divers et
varié et et ces questions se posent ou
peuvent se poser on a on a aussi le cas
de parents qui sont inquiets par rapport
au comportement de leurs enfants ou qui
pensent que qu'ils sont dans ils se
referment sur euxmême même donc parfois
on a reçu même des jeunes tout seul ou
parfois avec leurs parents qui se posent
des questions qui veulent comprendre et
d'ailleurs parfois on a eu aussi des
familles euh dans le le le comment dire
le le le fils ou la fille s converti à
l'islam et que les parents ne sont pas
du tout musulmans qui ont fait la
démarche où on a été sollicité par les
services de l'État ou des associations
spécialisées sur ces sujetslà donc c'est
un sujet qu'on euh qu'on rencontre assez
régulièrement le même si on dit même si
on dit que la radicalisation se fait en
en périphérie des mosquées apparemment
sauf les mosquées qui sont défin ou vu
comme extrémist globalement aujourd'hui
dire et d'ailleurs les chiffres du
ministère de l'Intérieur sur les
perquisitions y compris qui ont été bon
il y a eu quelques mosquées qui on qui
ont été perquisitionné en France et il y
en a eu deux dans les evvelines mais ce
que je veux dire sur les résultat des
perquisitions il y a rien il y a pas
grandchose il y a rien d'autangile donc
c'est sur la question que ça soit les
institutions qui organisent la
radicalisation jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
preuve n'en était pas faite en tout cas
dans les ivelines on n'est pas dans
cette on n pas pas de de de comment dire
d'éléments là-dessus maintenant la la le
ce qu'on constate au quotidien c'est
qu'en effet le public qui est très
sensible à comment dire à des idées
extrêmes qui est très souvent
relativement jeune il y a beaucoup de de
de de de converti aussi mais ils font
comment dire ils subissent ils font plus
partie d'un phénomène que nous aussi
mais on utilise le le le terme de de
dématérialisation de l'espace religieux
parce que très souvent en réalité donc
ils prennent leurs enseignements ou en
tout cas se rencontre via les réseaux
sociaux dans tel ou tel on dort
complètement des institutions
officielles des mosquées des salles de
prière ou même des des d'écoles
d'enseignement privé musulmans et ainsi
de suite donc c'est une aujourd'hui
c'est une vraie difficulté vous avez
aussi des vous pouvez avoir des
associations sec couvert culturel qui
font autre chose qui n'a rien à voir et
qui sont dans le cultuel donc on a un
mélange de genres voilà il y a déjà un
tri à à faire à ce niveau-là alors il y
avait aussi des portes ouvertes qui
avaient été proposées par par par
plusieurs mosqué en France euh on l'
organisé donc sur la question de de de
la radicalisation vous posez la question
de l'action du Simi tout à l'heure on a
parlé du milieu carcéral voilà tout à
l'heure on a parlé du milieu carcéral
donc en effet nous on travaille avec le
le SPIP qui nous avait sollicité pour
travailler sur un programme sur la
question de la déradicalisation on
travaille sur la question des homoniers
parce qu'il y a un manque très criant en
tout cas au niveau des évelines sur la
question d'homon musulmans dans dans les
prisons et ça pose beaucoup de questions
qui sont pas simples à résoudre à la
fois en terme de formation mais aussi en
terme de St en terme d'un certain nombre
de choses on est en train d' d'y
travailler et après on eff fait à
destination du grand public il y a eu
les portes ouvertes de toutes les
institutions en tout
cas une partie qui une bonne partie qui
a été organisée donc c'est quelque chose
qui est en train d'institutionnaliser et
puis il y a tout un cycle d'intervention
et de conférence débat qui est lancé sur
des thématiques de cet ordre pour
traiter le les sujets un mot de
conclusion
Maral rapidement de conclusions surt oui
surtout c'est fini déjà carrément moi je
pense que je vrais revenir sur le sens
de notre collectif euh en fait il y a 15
ans samire et moi on avait déjà monté ce
collectif croyance et laïité croyance et
laïcité et aujourd'hui il s'appelle
parole à cœur ouvert c'est tout un
programme et vousz changé oui et en fait
moi je dirais que aujourd'hui la
première urgence c'est pas tant de
convaincre mais c'est de comprendre
voilà pour essayer de comprendre merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à ce
débat ça va très vite donc c'était
passionnant très intéressant vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur le site de
TVfil
www.tvfil.com on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro bonne
[Musique]
soirée